hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to there
has been a war going on for years
it's caused bloodshed and Archy chaos
it's torn this world apart when you meet
someone for the first time an immediate
screening is needed that can be summed
up in one question and one question only
tangled or frozen strange to think but
there's a kind of rivalry among movie
fans about which one is better
Disney's version of Rapunzel or a
Disney's version of The Snow Queen it's
similar to the rivalries you'll see
among geeks sports fans and girls doomed
to disappointment but ask a shot to
discover the more and more I talk to
people the more they seem to really want
to pick a side if you say you like
frozen there's always someone that says
oh but tangled is so much better if you
say you like tango there's always
someone to say oh what's the point when
you have frozen so why in Arthas are
such a debate I mean nobody's comparing
Lion King to Aladdin or Little Mermaid
against Beauty and the Beast well maybe
well the reason says there does seem to
be a lot of similarities both films
focus on CGI princesses who already look
pretty similar poor optimistically perky
have an issue with a magical problem
come across a chiseled man who teaches
them the ways of the outside world
stumble across a comedic psychic and go
back and forth and saving each other
while trying to resolve their problem
why would there even be an issue with
these differences when they seem so much
alike well like anything there's going
to be some elements that are done better
than others one that most people can
agree with is the story even people who
love frozen acknowledge the story is not
the strongest part especially the back
story
there's curses and trolls and wiping out
memories and parents making downright
psychotic decisions it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense tangle most people
agree has a very flowing narrative it's
a good update of the classic fairy tale
that's easy to follow and easy to relate
to
make the argument the comic relief is a
little better too not that either film
rely on just one element for their
comedy thank God but there's certainly
our characters created mostly to get a
laugh we're the one in frozen is fine
but kind of typical the one in Tangled
stands out much much more how many times
have you seen a horse act like Tommy Lee
Jones from the future
it's such a bizarre idea but their
conviction to it completely sells us on
it resulting in a ton of laughs but
dangle has some weaknesses to the
villain for example seems to go back and
forth between trying to be menacing and
trying to be a silly obstacle where
other Disney villains balance comical
and threatening very well this one seems
to be half the energy at both which
makes a little harder to get invested in
her not to say the villain and frozen
was perfect but it was meant to be a
surprise which helped further the
message of the film and when the reveal
was shown he was surprisingly kind of
intimidating also the music well good is
still not as hummable as frozen even
with a similar sound the music to frozen
is a monster taking basic establishing
songs we've heard variations up for
years and using it to once again tell
the story and explain how a person feels
but on top of that they're just more
memorable he'll even to memorable
there's sing-alongs that are still all
over the place and they're still kids
everywhere that will not stop humming
these songs so yeah both seem to have
strengths they'll seem to have
weaknesses but why do so many people
demand that they choose which one they
like better
perhaps a big part of it is that they do
such a good job at the parts that people
like to compare I mean okay there's
details we can contrast like environment
timing style and so forth but the parts
people usually like most in a movie are
the characters and the ideas as
mentioned before these characters and
ideas are so similar it's almost
impossible not to naturally want to
compare them Anna has been sheltered
most of her life just like Rapunzel
resulting in a naive but get Ally
cheerful protagonist bland and Kristoff
has spent most of their lives in the
wild growing cynical but still a
charmingly offbeat personality and both
of them seem to make fun of Disney
tropes that have been popular for years
while also continuing others to still
make it profitable for example Flynn
asks why the heck everybody suddenly
burst into song I don't know if it
Disney character has ever done that
before
Rapunzel is also physically more active
than most Disney Princesses and I know a
lot of you may think of Mulan seeing how
she was not a princess oh yeah don't
believe their lies next issue frozen is
even more obvious with their dig at the
Disney tropes hammering in that you
can't just marry a guy you just met
no I think most people grow up figuring
this out for their own but Disney still
gives a lot of blame for instilling this
mindset of people even though I've yet
to meet a person who actually has this
mindset
I said person that's a nuisance but it's
still a Disney product and they
obviously are not going to abandon all
their cash cows so the people are still
gorgeous with the traditional big eyed
look they're still elegant outfits and
hairstyles we can parade into toys to
sell and there's still the message of
following your dreams and things will
turn out how you want we can mock these
all we want but there's no debating that
this is what most kids like to see and
thus most adults and her child's want to
see so it has both the adult interest
for something new and the childhood
interest with something familiar in
nostalgic however popularity wise
there's no contest frozen is still
everywhere tangled while hit at the box
office is nowhere near the numbers that
frozen polled in which leads to the last
and most likely reason why there's a
rivalry when one gets more attention
than the other everyone seems to be
praising frozen as a masterpiece but
when a film which looks and acts very
similar comes out first it doesn't seem
very fair if one film did these elements
first and in some people's eyes better
why isn't this everywhere as much as the
other one again tangled is definitely
known but nowhere near as big as frozen
there's even been a backlash that's been
forming around it of people saying it's
a downright terrible movie I've done
that toriel about this before about
whether or not hype can kill a film and
in some ways the popularity of frozen
has drawn many people away from it
calling it a bad movie we've seen this
happen with lots of films like My Big
Fat Greek Wedding The Dark Knight and
most recently Star Wars these are all
movies that most people would like fine
if they saw them on their own but when
combined with everyone saying it's
amazing it's one of the greatest things
ever can easily arouse um one the wrong
way it's hard to say frozen is a
terrible movie with so many actual
terrible movies out there but it's not
hard to see someone not liking it people
like and dislike things for various
reasons but in situations like this it's
much more appealing to root for the
underdog
a hipster argument I like the original
blank before the new blank I saw what
was perfect before society when it
screwed it all up
not that this argument can't be true
sometimes heck a lot of times but it
seems to be one we like to fall back on
a little too easily there are lots of
times where a predecessor is better but
people's acceptance or non acceptance of
it shouldn't make a difference whether
you like a newer film or an older film
doesn't automatically place you in a
certain category the reason someone
likes tangled over frozen could be
entirely different from why you like
tangled over frozen it's fun to share
likes and what you have in common but
acting like that suddenly makes you one
of them or one of us is just plain silly
it's not what you like or what you don't
like that makes you interesting is why
you like or don't like those things and
there's no right or wrong answer
comparing thoughts and opinions isn't
done to judge or separate at least it
shouldn't be it's done to understand and
connect but frozen and tangle can be
good films and if you like one better
than the other awesome sure why maybe
we'll find out something about you we
never knew before
they'll be similar arguments with
similar franchises and they'll no doubt
be a lot of fun to talk about but just
remember it is for fun we can learn a
lot from it but don't ever take it too
seriously
because whether it be comparing
ourselves or CGI Princesses chances are
there's a lot more in common than you
would think
emphasize frozen is better I'm gonna
stash your credit I remember so you
don't have to
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the Children's Miracle Network
this charity raises funds and awareness
for a hundred and seventy hospitals that
provide 32 million treatments each year
to kids across the United States and
Canada
now the donations stay local the fun
critical treatments and health care
services as well as pediatric medical
equipment and charitable care since 1983
this organization has raised more than
four point seven billion dollars most of
it just coming from one dollar donations
its various fundraising partners and
program support the nonprofit's mission
to save and improve the lives of as many
children as possible one of those
partners you might have heard of before
extra life org uniting thousands of
players around the world and a 24 hour
gaming marathon to support this
wonderful charity since 2008 extra
life.org has raised over 14 million
dollars for these hospitals you can see
they do a lot of work and if you go to
their YouTube channel you can also see
all the wonderful stories that they
share they have good people good
partnerships so definitely go check them
out and make a huge difference in the
child's life
you